[Musique]
chaque année aux césars il ya ce que
l'on appelle un moment gênant on se
rappelle tous d'un comédien ou d'une
comédienne qui a créé un malaise avec
une intervention un peu raté cette année
nous avons décidé de l'anticiper et de
le créer nous mêmes comme toi ce sera
fait voici donc le moment gênant de la
soirée il vous est proposé par monsieur
poulpe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous
bonsoir quel public ça me fait vraiment
plaisir de vous voir ce soir c'est la
grande soirée du cinéma et plein de
morts cette année
et pourtant je vois pas de sièges vides
vous avez vite remplacé quand même hein
c'est pas comme neymar sais pas
c'est pas je vois par exemple s'il ya
plein de monde il ya guillaume canet ce
soir guillaume est tenue à l'équitation
ou quoi docteur paul sûreté principal et
quand tu travailles tu as ton 2 tu
changes de sabots ou quoi et vanessa
paradis
[Musique]
et quand je vous dis c'est vous dis très
bonne idée césar 2010 8 c c'était long
que c'était peut-être trop long en fait
j'ai peut-être qu'on va peut-être on va
commencer d'abord par la salle et après
le balcon ça marchera peut-être le
balcon premier à ne reste qu'une balle
qu'on sait filmer les gens c'est filmé
jean ça passe à la télé ça passe à la
télé oui en ce moment c'est en train de
passer à la télé ah ok ok et michel az
have a appuyé m messieurs la ville un
sound
j'ai un job olivier nakache alors ça va
de reprendre le travail de godard ça
marche pas et olivier savate et planck
tu vas aller chercher chez truffaut
ça marche pas ça marche que du coup pas
changé et pas grave ça y est on a tous
été gêné bravo on l'a vu naître mais
manger non jamais
une petite blague sur semblant
battements par minute
banana il c'est bon on a eu le moment
gênant c'est déconseillé aux moins de 14
ans alors que ça fait même poppers
bon voilà au moins c'est fait on peut
continuer là s'est révélée plus
tranquille